what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python tutorial this tutorial is
gonna be concerning the module called
send keys the purpose of some keys is
well to send some keys and so you can
open up a program and type in that
program as if you were typing on your
keyboard right so it's a little bit
different obviously you can output
various bits of text you can save text
to a file but sometimes if you want to
or sometimes you may want to literally
send keys as if you were typing on a
keyboard so with that many do some
basics of this module send keys and the
first thing that we're gonna have to do
is download send keys you can get the
tarball you can do pip install you can
which all your favorite installation
tactics the easiest way to get and
install it however is to use the
following link here I won't put it in
the description if I remember if I don't
remember someone comment and I'll add it
to this description and you'll want to
download you know the 32-bit or 64-bit
and then whatever version of Python you
have hopefully two seven once you've
done that and installed it you'll be
able to come over to your script and
usually it's always a good idea to check
your insulation so bring over a quick
interpreter and type in import capital
Sen D capital K ey s as long as you
don't have an error there good job you
do have an error something went wrong in
the installation you can't figure it out
feel free to leave a comment below
moving right along to our script all we
really need here is import send keys
just like we did a second ago although
I'm also gonna go ahead and import time
because we'll use that as a bit of a
sleeper so I can click away from the
script and open up a notepad or at least
click on the notepad so that's where
it'll type so we'll have time for now
the next thing that we want to do is
let's just define main and as usual try
except exception me print string try
what do we want to do first let's say
the string so we'll say send me that's
gonna be their string and we're just
gonna have it say hello for now and then
we're gonna have time sleep we're gonna
two seconds and then what we want to do
is actually activate the send key so
sent activating send keys is as simple
as I'm gonna copy and paste this send
Keys dot send keys and what you want to
do is put whatever you want to send in
here so in our case we want to do send
me and that's really it so I'm gonna
call main down here man and let me bring
up a notepad real quick so we're ready
to rhumble when it's when we run this so
come over here save that run that let me
bring my mouse over here and in a second
yeah there we go so typed out hello for
us now if you want to take it a step
further and have it say hello there
you'll quickly find that it's not the
best so we'll run it again I'm just
gonna delete that and as you can see it
did hello there but it didn't do this
space for us so some of our smarter
folks will be like ah I know what to do
I know what to do and they'll do this
and so let's see what happens if we use
the space key even though we already
have some there nope does it exactly
pretty annoying what what you can do
there's a couple of methods you could
use to get around this one method would
be literally using these brackets cuz
you can do a few things so like if you
use these brackets and type in capital
space like so we can bring this file
over let's run that again and this time
it should do yeah so hello space there
you can do all kinds of other things too
like you can do a back space so it'll be
held there basically it's what we're
gonna get with this shoot interesting
that it was all caps
oh shoot let's see
Oh Mike Mike Katz was I had my caps lock
on on my keyboard oh say what they
anyway let's run that one more time so
held there so anyway you knew backspace
you can also do enter so if you needed
it to actually hit the enter key it was
a it's able to do that for you so I'll
just leave it there so now you've got
hello there you know got my Enter key
why do I keep it know why I keep hitting
my enter or I mean my caps lock
oh because we're typing it in here it's
like classic you haven't anyway the next
thing that you can do is you can have it
like natively recognize spaces obviously
you can have it natively recognize enter
but you can have it natively recognize
newline and I'll show you guys that in a
second so let's say you want hello there
and what you can do is in the send Keys
function there are all kinds of
parameters that you can put in here so
you can have it do recognize spaces new
lines tabs and you can have it turn off
the number lock because it wants to
natively use number lock so let's say we
want to have it recognize spaces so to
do that with underscore spaces equals
set that to true and we can also do
we'll leave that for now so let's say we
want that space so they went now when we
run this we come over here hello there
cool and then what if we did want a new
line let's run it come over here hello
there so as you can see it didn't do a
new line but then you can say with
underscore new lines equals true save it
run it come over here and you see it
made a new lawn for us now that pretty
much covers what I wanted to show you
guys the last thing I'll show you guys
is the combination of this plus another
tutorial I did as far as how to make
Python open things up so I put in a
notepad file called example dot text in
the same directory as a script some
in port OS and then we're gonna go here
and we're going to say OS dot start file
and we want to start example dot txt so
this will open up example dot txt this
will specify ok hey we want to this is
what we want to send it's going to sleep
for we'll just change this now to a half
a second early and then it's going to go
ahead and send the keys to that program
so let's go ahead and run this now and
it brings us it was kind of not there so
let's try that again don't say there we
go so that time you saw it you know it
opens up notepad types in the notepad so
some programs are a lot of programs can
be controlled very easily by just the
keyboard right you don't need your mouse
and so you can do all kinds of various
things like this and in the bracket so
you can put all kinds of other keys that
you might like page up page down insert
key you've got your alt keys ctrl key
and all that kind of stuff so there's
all kinds of things that you can do with
send keys so that's it for the 7 keys
tutorial hopefully I helped some of you
guys out or at least you found it
interesting as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time